well hello there watching uh the press
preview coming up
uh in the next half hour or so then
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire welcome to both of
you
good morning anna so to tomorrow's front
pages let's start with the metro
reporting that
for the first time the second the number
of second cover jabs administered in a
single day was more than
first doses the telegraph quotes the
labour leader serkir stama
describing the notion of so-called
vaccine passports
as unbritish the queen has been seen
back out in public without a face mask
after receiving her second vaccine dose
that's the front page of the sun the
daily mail reports that the charity
watchdog
is investigating the zoo where the prime
minister's fiancee
carries simon's works the government
commissioned report on racial
disparities
in the uk has been described as divisive
and a missed opportunity for change
that's the lead for the guardian
while the times carries similar
criticism with the report described as
culturally deaf the financial times
still
relays disappointing initial results for
deliveroo
after the takeaway firm's floatation on
the long
london stock exchange if i can say that
uh wallpaper is obviously due to come in
entrepreneurs kevin mcguire are here
you want to kick off kevin why don't you
with the daily telegraph
um this idea about vaccine passports and
what labor think of it what what's the
great reveal tonight then
yeah it's kierst starman the labour
leader saying he thinks they're uh
on british is instinct is that they are
not
british because you have to show your
papers to get
into a a this puts big pressure on
the government boris johnson who well
one day was in
favor of them the next day he wasn't but
if he wishes to push it through
with the liberal democrats and uh a
reasonable chunk of his own party
against it he might struggle to get
through the house of commons but later
also
opposed um he does qualify it kierstar
by saying if if the system comes in it
shouldn't be left
to pub landlords to decide whether or
not it operates i think that's that's uh
that's quite but it's cool it's
it's an interesting intervention and the
phrasing about
it's not british it's clearly he's
attempting to appear
uh patriotic go for that uh patriotic uh
vote uh
lisa nandy the shadow foreign secretary
made
was billed as a keynote speech today or
on that on that subject and
it's it's right into the telegraph uh
territory so there we are we've got uh
the labor leader gary
very suppor supportive tory newspaper
he's got the splash
uh and he's not criticized for it
doesn't normally happen to a labor
leader that
yes i mean is there a sense of
inevitability about some sort of
certification or passport for foreign
travel
and really even for the tory party the
question is how far do you take this
andrew well you know we talked about
this a bit before and
i i can't stand all this um uh
nanny state that the government has to
tell us what we can and can't do
but i still have this feeling that um a
passport system
is just going to evolve naturally anna i
think it will be
commercial there'll be commercial
pressures will dictate it i think we
we could well see it happening in
theaters in concert halls
and i think a lot of people will support
it now i
i don't want i don't want it to happen
but i think it is inevitable
and i saw there was a poll today i've
forgotten who did the poll
but it showed pretty strong public
support
or some form of passport scheme because
people want to get on with their lives
they want to lead normal lives as best
they can
and if they think they can do that best
by going to a restaurant where
you do have to show some form of id i.e
you've had the back twice um i think
it's probably going to happen
i think it's going to be very difficult
for a government to say it can't happen
equally i don't want the government to
say they're going to enforce it
so i know kevin thinks it shouldn't be
left to uh
pubs or restaurateurs but um i'd rather
they took that decision
then the government starts bullying and
ordering
firms which have already had enough on
their plate in the last year to be
burdened with another layer of
impenetrable bureaucracy
yeah and we've got all those issues of
the vaccine statement 100
different variants have different
efficacy and all those issues so you
you want to crack on as it were if
you've had your two shots plus one week
but you don't
you don't know what you're letting
yourself in for necessarily as we as we
head head forward but anyway
should we move on i see the daily
telegraph also is covering the macro
announcing fresh lockdown for the
whole of france um talking about well
he's he's got his own he's got himself
to blame for that hasn't he
if he hadn't if he hadn't pulled such
contempt
and scorn on the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine most of france could a lot more
of france could have
could have been vaccinated by now
instead he decided to take pot shots
at the vaccine because it's british he
had absolutely no evidence to support
the fact
it is not a efficient and effective for
people over the age of 65.
he knows in france that it's a country
that is very reluctant to be
to take vaccines anyway so he's done
huge damage
to his own public health program because
of his stupidity
and his arrogance and now they're in a
major national lockdown
and that's going to cause him huge
political problems and he's brought it
all on himself
well he has promised that um the
continental the eu will be the biggest
vaccine producer
in the world which takes us to the the
front page of the financial times
um and this once again is what brussels
does
about the astrazeneca vaccine which is
produced on eu
soil bring us up to date kevin yeah this
is uh
terry uh breton who's the internal
market commissioner
there we are zero jobs will cross the
channel when astrazeneca hits its target
and that's because astrazeneca promised
the eu countries 120 million
jabs in the first three months of this
year it's going to deliver 30
second three months april to june
promised 180 million
probably going to deliver 70 million so
astrazeneca
jabs uh produced in holland and belgium
the threat is returning will they be
allowed
to come to britain now of course
astrazeneca is producing two plants here
in in in britain in oxfordshire uh
and i think the is the other um
staffordshire or i think might be three
because there's a wreck someone as well
so
england and wales but not have been
exported they've all been
used here so i can see why now the
european union
some of the countries and uh i mean tory
boy is right for one something amazing
about macron getting this this wrong you
go around
france you you can't move for pharmacies
it's
almost like a nation of hypochondriacs
but they like a few other countries or
on the on the continent they they
completely
botched the the jab the uh immunization
program and it seems they they now want
these uh
these jobs that they don't trust and
keep putting restriction on but they
but they want them also because of
criticism uh and
you could see unless the uk which is
is ordered was it 300 million plus
now far more than we will ever need
unless we agree to somehow
share we're going to have a problem and
this vaccine nationalism i think it's
terrible because the only way you can
defeat a pandemic which is a global
event is globally
but we've seen that in india the
government there is
restricting uh restricted exports early
on in the pandemic
the uk imposed an embargo on the export
of some
chemicals and some uh medicine so
we haven't got completely clean hands in
this
this either but you hope uh it'll be
avoided this war
but you can see also why it's bubbling
up when astrazeneca
anglo-swedish country isn't felt by the
european commission
to be delivering on the contracts itself
can i just say could germany start using
the four million that are stuck in
fridges
across the whole country of germany the
the the eu have lost the plot completely
here
large parts of the eu keep saying we
don't want to use the astrazeneca
vaccine and yet you've got this
ridiculous eu commissioner
now threatening another trade war over
astrazeneca germany has four
million unused astrazeneca vaccines what
is going on
they can't have it both ways kevin yet
they wanted it both ways
they're trying to just yet again divert
attention from their
shambles that is their procurement
policy it's a champion
i i've pointed out time after time the
contradiction
between some european countries saying
the astrazeneca
vaccine isn't safe you can't use it
various categories and then the clamor
to actually get it and the threat of a
vaccine war
in order to get the deliveries but as
the eu
ramps up uh its injection program it
gets going you will see
they will need the supplies an
astrozenica
it's a typical biological process
producing a vaccine
it's not you can't just turn it on and
off very very easily
but you can see they've over committed
there is this suggestion that they've
sold the same vaccines twice
or more times so they just can't fulfill
their orders
yes uh keel oxford and then fill and
finish in wrexham isn't it for the
astrazeneca uh in this country um let's
go to the sun then you talked about
everybody wanting to get out and about
once they've had their their vaccines
um uh the queen has had her second back
out with no mask
uh 99 take up the dose
the second dose and for the first time
today we've seen more
second doses than first doses which was
predicted for well
april i know it's still it's the end of
march isn't it andrew but uh
moving on then yeah and it's good
it's good to see so another half million
jabs were done in the last 24 hours but
as you say the first time
the second jabs outweighed the first
jabs and that's a real sign of progress
we are really reaching out more and more
great to see the queen out it's her
first official engagement i think of the
year
she was at runnymede and it was through
mark the centenary of the australian
royal air force so
he's nodding to the commonwealth as well
uh and um
she's not wearing a mask i know but but
she's had a second job perhaps she feels
she doesn't have to she'd have taken
advice on that by the way um
uh and if they thought she should be
wearing a a mars she would have done
uh but it was fantastic so it's a sort
of debatable issue isn't it whether she
should be seen out there with one
and what that says to people but anyway
just quickly if you don't mind can we do
the daily telegraph story
which is about hospital-acquired covert
infection which is a really important
story which often doesn't get enough
coverage in my view one in five they
think deaths
um came from infections acquired on
wards then kevin
yeah no absolutely free of information
requests although i have i think
these figures ring a bell an earlier
paper review maybe it was even in the
telegraph
but that one in five people who died in
hospital of coburg caught it
in hospital infections are a huge
problem in
in in hospitals i know the nhs does a
huge amount to try and
resolve it in the fact is you've got a
lot of very ill and infectious people
in hospitals and trying to stop and kill
others uh
is going to be a priority but that's uh
still at the same time is a shocking
figure
the queen's 197 or something now uh and
if she's had her second job and uh
because of because of her age and she
doesn't have to wear a mask i think the
phase we're going
through now actually is it's good some
people are seeing around without masks
we gotta get we gotta return the
life normal we don't wanna blow it all
of a sudden as uh matt hancock health
secretary is worried about
the same time she's outside and there's
very very little evidence
that you actually get this virus outside
okay
interesting um thank you for now plenty
more still to come including a report
says britain
is not an institutionally racist country
but that hasn't satisfied everyone
more on that just
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearson kevin
mcguire welcome back to both of you
top of the guardian then leading on this
downing street commissioned
race report which has been criticized
all day has it not kevin
it has a job done uh if you're downing
street they
uh gave out a summary which is very
unusual certainly not the full
full report so they've got glowing
headlines in the papers today
that are britain's a great beacon of
racial equality there's no structural
racism and everything and the guardian
is the only paper i've seen so far
to put it on the front prominently and
picking up now uh on me and the
criticism
who would have thought that a prime
minister
who called black people picking ease
with water melon
smiles might be able to get a report
saying that there's no structural racism
in the the institutions he had who'd
have thought that
job done for him i suppose the argument
is they didn't say there was none
but that that is an automatic default
setting for people blaming
stuff on staff effectively no structural
racism you've got more uh
black uh asian ethnic minority people
babe i know it's a
a name they they want banned but you've
got more in prison more stopped by the
police you've got lower pay
across there's got to be some structural
racism it's just
look over deaths it was dying most you
saw the black and brown faces
of nhs staff dying early on is that
that's structural racism
is there and yet there's this denial
that johnson is
laughing he's absolutely laughing he'll
look pandered
to those in the the white community
who think there is no racism and every
time a man a black or
an asian another ethnic minority person
complains they're just someone playing
a race card that's what he was doing
himself johnson he knows exactly it's
really really silly
okay um andrew i apologize i'm not
getting your thoughts on that because
we've got a couple more stories want to
squeeze in i'll just say one thing
i'll just say one thing about it ten
people wrote that report nine of them
were black and ethnic
nine of them out of the ten now we'll
move on david cameron we're talking
about david cameron
he's sleeping he's you know kevin you're
saying
david cameron filling his boots still
saying nothing
the controversy goes on we now know that
the guy from green cell
had a card when he was working in number
10
with his business card with number 10 on
it we know that cameron according to
reports thought he could make up to 44
million pounds
of his links with greensville which he's
going under cameron will say nothing
about this
he'll keep his head down and hope that
the uh the flat will fly
over the top of his head but quite a lot
of it is landing on him i'm afraid
and uh finally payday for gambling
website boss denise coats pictured in
the guardian also in the telegraph
built this company i think it's in
gambling it's a poorer people people
with
little money who who uh suffer most uh
from gambling or lose most
in in gambling as a proportion of their
earnings look
everybody's entitled to make uh make a
living for one person
for instance to be paid more than almost
all the 100 footsie
company chiefs put together who are on
huge salaries themselves to get a lot of
criticism
i mean that's just ridiculous 1.1.3
million a day
and her pay since 2016 is now nearly 1.3
billion
that company gives that company gives
money to the labour party you know
they shouldn't take any from them well
that's it that is the subject we'll have
to discuss more at 11 30 because we've
run out of time we'll see you then thank
you very very much indeed
don't forget you can catch up uh uh the
very latest on that
as well on the youtube channel